chi sarà un lingua sera aiuto
riconciliando bianco dimmi un po io non
so come sta ma oggi finalmente lontano
da monaco la nuovissima ma faccio appena
uscita non glielo abbiamo visto niente
ora che usciti nuovi cappelli e nuove
tute mi sembrano keskin reagiremo tutto
assieme a voi anzi daremo un voto a
tutti i nuovi cappella e alle nuove
skill nuovi pezzi in pioggia che remo
assieme a voi nella nuova mappa se
questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace ci sarà un altro episodio della
nuova mappa quindi spalleggiare subito
cazzotto mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn entusiamo e con sicuro allora una
delle novità è che bisogna creare il
proprio account di più poi mi è uscita
la mappa abbiamo provato a entrare nel
gioco per vedere se funzionava e tutto
però continuamente cresceva non
funzionava niente perché c'erano
migliaia centinaia di migliaia di
persone che volevano vedere la nuova
mappa quindi il server più vista presa
anche voi avete provato a entrare nel
gioco con la nuova mappa e sono in cui
uscita ma se siete riusciti ma ora
fortunatamente non s'era tutto andiamo
subito ricordiamo innanzitutto a vedere
i gol cappellini e vediamo diamo un voto
allora 1984 sopracciglia bellissimo
perché sempre arrabbiati non 9 10 che me
lo voglio subito la cache
niente è bellissimo voto 10 abbiamo pure
noi abbiamo il cu rizzi non bello adoro
10 anche questo bellissimo qui abbiamo i
cappelli con la cosa a mio capito bene
allora questo gli do un 8 solo perché
non si può scegliere il colore di
capelli
mi dispiace io che cosa è questo una
cresta di gallo forse non sa che cosa mi
piace tanto a 15
no vabbè questo 10 e lode a giorgio
groppo c'è il coro dell'unicorno ma c'è
anche la criniera lago da una cerniera
sembrano zitto cerniera fatto un altro
tipo un cellulare una telecamera e
un'infermiera 8 o noto e mezzo 9 e poi
se non sbaglio questi si erano mosse da
allora il mio preferito tra quelli nuovi
e sono indecisa tra il cuoricino e
questo unicorno ma direi questo unicorno
è bellissimo il tuo invece è
sopraccigliare così allora questi erano
quelli gratuiti vediamo quelli a
pagamento se la nuova skin da cyborg
praticamente divide il personaggio il
cru mail in due
vedete se una parte tipo di metallo e
baffoni roster b nator poi abbiamo
semplice cappellino nero e di do un 5
non è niente di speciale casa io
e in quelli con le cuffie da un 72
frecciarossa 8 solido 97 e mezza per
l'eleganza dei cappello rosas e
cappellini natura allora i pezzi mi sa
che mi sono sbagliato perché mi sembrano
tutti gli stand forzati limoni diverso
non me lo ricordo questo cielo sa che
non hanno aggiunto per vini come il kiss
nuove abbiamo cyborg tipo un mezzo
ghiacciato e questo perché ora che
abbiamo visto tutta la verità vediamo
come la nuova moda per curia si può
salire da qui per cercare aspetta che
così sembra enorme allora iniziamo da fa
da iniziamo d'acqua vediamo tv pazienti
buona camera da letto provata non si può
aprire stanze private il che per
l'imposta re sarà insomma dire
nascondersi quale delle pulizie qui
puoi dirci la vostra stanza preferita
anche noi vi diciamo la nostra questa
cosa qua per te perché è diminuita la
luce è un'altra questa abbastanza di
sviluppo delle fotografie di herbert
macché figlio quindi solo qua è
diminuita la luce per l'impostore sarà
molto facile
un'altra stanzetta privata con delle
scarse quale per scendere un altopiano a
bisogna cliccare hughes non eletti con
un sotterraneo
anche questa mappa quanto grande
elettrica tutto abbiamo distanza non è
che ci sono anche delle nuove tac
quindi bisogna anche trovare le nuove
tac quindi questa è tutta la zona
electric e giù poi vediamo che cosa
abbiamo qua qua abbiamo vinto ma che
cosa sono questi mostri clinica o sono
il primo lo usano doveva tipo dal dottor
esatto si guarda ma quindi queste tipo
il dottore dice rosso scheletro intero
ci sono e pico la bilancia poi vediamo
se la sala d'attesa che carino guarda
c'è l'acqua qua con è troppo carina
ambientali hanno messo un sacco di
miniature alcuni bersagli il magazzino
delle cappelle forse magazzino poi verso
le scatole
ero ragazzino impara da dietro vediamo i
vari cappella forse in questa navicella
e questa aereo vendiamo i cappelli
noi pensiamo già viene
no si apre aennino va beh immagino
l'impostore che elimina nei bar che sarà
lingua sera aiuto di confagri no vabbè
finora questa è la mia mappa brevini
siamo davanti se il biliardo le
[Musica]
si può andare di qua anche se questo
libro vera dico ma sala relax si forse
non libreria no vabbè enorme passato che
cos'è una palestra che cos'è un tipo le
docce uno spogliatoio lo vogliate o
conte grande sembra tipo proprio la casa
dei più mette quasi la doccia un
asciugamano avessimo davvero bellissima
dove si va invece una porta è attento a
non cadere l'ascensore che cos'è voi che
cosa abbiamo qua
qui dove stavano clay ok almeno sappiamo
che una parte l'abbiamo esplorata tutta
poiché sappiamo questo brown rido io
faccio una matita sicilia vi segnalo le
scale e c'è un vento è praticamente
questo spazio sarà solo per l'impostore
wow
no perché qui c'è poi da fare qualche
test sicuramente vedo che c'è una task è
lì che dice cucina temeva cucina celano
gila ma allora furono una casa gigante a
posto per piumetto una casa 9 voglio
andare in cucina vogliono veramente
evitare vuole andare cucina quando
giocheremo vitale si saprà sempre dove
abbiamo non abbiamo esplorato quest'area
aspettare il suo qua proviamo qua qua
c'è un'altra persona
da qui le tasche per fare le tasche
nelle tasche nuove che non vedo l'ora di
vedere pd michele possiamo usare o
almeno di mikel impostore può usare
queste nuove ma qui ci regala vicina ma
che bello conoscere i piatti qua no che
buffon verona che cucinare allora mi si
può fare posto ai pomodori
ok non penso che qui è la ricetta ok
partito nino cipolla spola poi una
cipolla pomodoro o e il panino di sopra
è vegetariano come noi facciamo una
padella sul fuoco li attenzionate suo
infortunio per le foto di non lo so
faticano meno famosi
alle camere lega ma queste sono a colori
no si possono vedere tutte state
coinvolte c'è scritto tipo cassaforte
bisogna imparare a memoria tutti i nomi
adesso meeting room
non vedo l'ora di spiare tutti da questo
80 quasi un'altra porta ma non si può
entrare in quella porta non ci perdiamo
è una mappa poi per vedere fare il
balcone per vederlo passiamo di nuovi
video che quasi mille litri è un
labirinto cioè sono sicura che ci si può
trovare un'altra area faccio un altro
balcone ma questi pezzi forse in una
cassa bisognerà prendere questi pezzi
altre armi weizen contributore queste
armi da impostori che cosa nostra stanza
con un telefono novabell sala della
direzione tipo di lavoro ma si può
controllare l'aereo tipo qui puoi fare
una task questa qua uno va beh è troppo
bella sua mappa vediamo se abbiamo
esplorato tutto meeting room si
fondavano prendiamo a vederla subito che
cosa è un cappello da mago perché sembra
una person mostra miti mondiale
oro che cos'è da museo
ci sono varie armi varie cose si sono di
crewe mezzo pupazzi ma questo diamanti a
cosa servono di scoprirla ma tra l'altro
una delle tasche di pulire il bagno
bellissime questa tesi manca di
esplorare qua sopra meeting meeting in
cui c'è il pulsante quasi una porta
forse durante il gioco e lo scopriremo
presto ci si può teletrasportare da una
parte all'altra locali a dirigere un
punto veramente bisogna attraversare
tessuto che cos'è vediamo mai visto il
minimal rimasto bloccato
ok se non fai abbiamo esplorato tutto
spero non abbiamo spronato tutto
esploreremo in una partita prepariamoci
una vera partita secondo me sarà il caos
più totale
sia perché voi non vi siete ancora
perché è normale che vorrebbe giocare
con noi
seguiteci su in rome il nome anida store
ok allora siamo da 30 40 firmati da
mezz'ora che stiamo cercando di entrare
in pratica ci sono un sacco di problemi
con il server più condiviso il codice su
installiamo mano non riuscivate a
entrare avevate problemi anche voi
perché bisogna aggiornare il gioco
comunque ora anche se siamo solo 8 di
dieci perché appunto non riuscivano ad
entrare non funziona iniziamo la stesso
perché ho paura che crasso nuovamente
quindi vi è entrato un altro io vitale
stiamo giocando separati quindi non
guardare
ora sicura che vi perderete tutti nella
nuova mappa funziona funziona
questo non lo so vediamo
in pratica in con questo nuovo
aggiornamento si può scegliere da dove
iniziare
c'è qualcuno in bagno o come base ha
sentito il rumore spiare il mio tempo ho
sentito solo il rumore è troppo
divertente in una mappa questi grande ma
tutto può cambiare
hanno accesso gli automatica ma io sono
stato io
la nuova ne mazzola avviene le partite
ma nelle nuvole perché il nostro aereo
che fino a che ci si può teletrasportare
già adoro troppo questa mano come
reporter le cose bianco che sta
cucinando qualcosa che come cucinando
bianco dimmi un po io non so come sta ma
si è sentito un uomo alta maturo minori
viario che ora non si sta spiando sono
72 i a dare tutto posto ad acqua no
vabbè troppo bello giocare ad amuda due
a un altro gioco troppo bello
non so dove sto andando gli usa menzione
come ma no visto che nottata non l'ho
fatto
qualcuno ha sempre dato qualcosa aiuto
bisogno per cavani
no facciamo un'altra partita c'è asterrò
suisse si aspetta infantino ben fatto
sono tornato arancione posso vedere il
cappello adesso fanno guardare non
guardare ancora aspetta
siamo ok allora quali sono le tasche da
fare allora
come faccio a capire dove devo andare
allora nella meeting room dove la
meeting room
meeting room sta comprando niente ho
visto da vicino la meeting wroom devo
salire sopra per fare questa task che
prendiamo questa sottospecie di
ascensore e come si fa a riavere la sua
buffa e rhone guardare qui e ora non
posso andare a ecco renato l'ascensore
andiamo un urlo l'istituto
nell'ascensore allora smontandola
meeting room forse qua è impossibile
orientarsi e allora che grosso è che
tale sta parlando in modo un po strano
arancione e chi no io stavo giù in
cucina comunque state eliminate quattro
persone io voto 1 a caso marrone sono
perché non lo so mi sembra sosta trono
votato anch'io
vediamo se non nei marosi fu ferito
salvo no vero
ma magari norma infatti non capisco
vabbè io però vorrei andare nella ok se
non è la vita in rome
devo mettere la idrico dove come al
solito non la task e allora 784 31
andare a salvare la passat un aiuto si
no quel cambiato 4 0 1 43 tutti quasi
tutti qua ok hai ragione su morrone
essere nuova diamo anche se secondo me è
di per sé verso persone un altro
episodio in cui giochi un cubo e spolli
state passato e ora mi lascia un po
quando ciò che sa indicare però dei
nostri altri video in caso quella che
preferite